hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we are back with
more glorious jujitsu based shenanigans
on the quest to recruit kinji hikari
into the culling game fun times and at
the moment i'm not sure if that's going
too well or not but if you'd like to set
a positive chain of events into motion
then do subscribe to the new world
review which will result in consistent
injections of curse-based culture
administered directly into your youtube
feed now with that simultaneously
shameful and yet shameless
self-promotion over this chapter flips
the perspective of our previous
installment where 153 was pretty much
all about yuji and hikari 154 takes the
time to zoom in on the supporting cast
of this plot being hoshi megami and
pandumi with the most intriguing of the
three to me being hoshi because whilst
we don't know exactly what it is yet we
are treated to a very intriguing curse
technique very evocative of gojo
actually because it has a similar effect
of not allowing people to achieve a
certain distance and i do have one
fairly crazy idea as to what this might
be because there are a fair few clues in
the chapter it's obviously nothing
anywhere near as crazy as limitless
which just casually proceeds to break
the very world it exists in but during
my video on the last chapter i actually
said that hoshi's piercings remind me of
star constellations just a random
offhand comment because hoshi means
quite literally star in japanese and i
think i've been very much poisoned by
that thought because i'm now wondering
if hoshi's cursed technique is all about
creating constellations because what
appears to happen is that hoshi marks
someone or something with a star and
whoever is marked with that star is then
assigned a position that they must
retain at least in relation to the other
stars around them so an intriguing
example of that in this chapter is
megami who cannot get close to hoshi but
who also seemingly cannot remove himself
from the proximity of divine dog so
whether this wacky idea is true or not i
think it would be quite fascinating to
see a curse technique work in this way
let's say that hoshi has to select a
certain constellation formation and then
stars can be assigned as needed it would
be fun because you could also change up
the constellation to suit your various
needs and also hoshi could form a part
of this constellation as well because of
all of the other stars in i's business
if anything it does actually look like
hoshi is self-marked with whatever
technique this is and that would make
this curse technique quite balanced
because you'd essentially be applying
the same rules to yourself as to your
opponent except you would know what the
game is which is a big advantage with
that said it could also be something
significantly more simple and magnetism
also comes to mind maybe being able to
mark targets with a certain polarity and
just mess with the world that way under
whatever other conditions are required
to use the curse technique but i will
say in favor of the star theory is that
panda has something quite curious
written on his butt along with the star
it says imai which to the best of my
knowledge means new residence in
japanese so that is well it's an
intriguing thing to be written on the
posterior of a panda although looking at
it from a very surface level tin foil
hat perspective apparently imai is the
name of a star and one of the four that
collectively craft a very simple
constellation known as the crux which is
basically just four stars in a cross
shape by far one of the simplest
constellations you can imagine so look
this might just be a pretty radical
coincidence and perhaps umai does have
another japanese meaning that i'm
unaware of my japanese is as always
pathetic maybe it's even a term
referring to magnetism in some way but
until proven otherwise i'm actually
pretty keen on my crackpot constellation
thoughts no matter what it turns out to
be though i'm curious as to how hoshi
actually marked megami because he wasn't
touched in any way like divine dog
appears to have been what's also very
curious is that akutami takes some very
specific space to show the dropping of a
phone and it's quite unclear exactly
what happened here because hoshi takes
the phone out holds it in left hand but
then divine dog strikes the phone is
nowhere to be seen but then we see both
the phone and divine dog repelled and
i'm probably just reading too much into
this because that's the thing that i do
but it does make me wonder if the phone
might have been marked with a star as
well and it's forming part of the
technique here either that or akatami is
just making a point of having hershey
drop the phone to emphasize that we can
now no longer contact hakari sometimes
things don't need to be quite as
complicated as i may make them out to be
i just find it very interesting because
drawing manga is an
extraordinarily time time-consuming
process and artists learn very quickly
not to draw superfluous stuff so when i
see a panel like this i just ask myself
alright so what was their intention here
because potentially hours of work went
into this singular panel so akutami must
have thought it to be very important
either in a technical sense of ability
or for the sake of narrative now of
course something i haven't mentioned yet
is the gender reveal of hoshi kirara we
do take some time out of this chapter to
quite blatantly state that hoshi is male
at least biologically i suppose and i
think the question does come up here
because kirara is actually a very
classically female name like not in the
way that hoshi kirar's name is composed
because that's a very strange cobbling
together of kanji but the more common
kanji combination for kirara contains
the symbols for both cloud and mother
which is why i think megami twigs here
because he hears the name kirara and
he's all like kirara i thought that the
other third year was a male student
which to put into an english context i
don't know suppose imagine hearing a
name like say stephanie and then being
told that stephanie is a man that's what
i think is happening with megami here
the gender expectations being flipped on
him which is actually quite ironic
coming from one megumi fushiguro whose
first name is also classically
attributed to being female so this does
seem to be perhaps an emerging motif
with akutami purposely subverting gender
expectations and hey in a very rare
instance for shona manga we might
actually have a legit lgbt relationship
happening with hoshi and hakari which i
do think is worth pointing out if that
is indeed the case because yeah it's far
from a first for shona manga but it
generally wouldn't be shown so
explicitly they'd usually be buried
behind a mountain of subtext meanwhile i
think my genuine highlight of this
chapter is this nice sliver of darkness
actually my favorite panel by far has to
be this shot of megami emerging from the
shadow of some dude but it's
terrifyingly cool almost like a shark
skillfully and patiently hunting its
prey below the deep dark waters i say
this a lot about megami but i swear he
just continues to get better and better
with every passing off because he just
keeps diversifying his skill set and
being generally awesome he's one of the
many characters who could take the
mantle of protagonist in the event that
yuji was magically erased from the
series somehow because i for one would
quite happily follow the tale of megumi
fushiguru still curious as to how he's
going to react to this whole zenin
clan's slaughter business because unless
i've missed something i'm assuming that
this hakari recruitment business is
happening in tandem with maki's quest
for very specific blood and just while
we're on that actually a couple of
people did bring a great idea to my
attention regarding the whole sort of
business because i previously mentioned
how shocked i was that a character like
narya was just up and killed in front of
our eyes but several of you did point
out the very real possibility of him
returning as some sort of vengeful
cursed spirit which could definitely be
very fun and perhaps even set up a
machinalia rematch down the line maybe
even now your megami because they do
have all sorts of head clan business
together sort of mean one would be dead
and can't be the head and the other is
the head but doesn't want to be the head
i don't know man zen in politics are
complicated still i just wanted to throw
that out there because it is a fun idea
and i'd be more than happy to have naya
continue in that kind of very twisted
capacity back to 154 though how can we
ignore best boy panda he has by far the
most adorable panel of the chapter
pretending to be a lovable cute bear
creature playing with his toy tire not
that any of that statement is actually
untrue he is a lovable bear playing with
attire but it was a great source of
comedy especially contrasting this shot
against panda's next panel which is this
extremely detailed close-up where he
seems the most human i think he's ever
looked it just has something to do with
the sheer intensity of expression and
detail given to his shading at least
compared to the flat almost cartoonish
panda of the previous panel and it's all
just very surreal because let's let's
just take the most reasonable case
scenario from the perspective of the two
schmucks let's say that we're not
thinking that panda is a cursed
energy-wielding hyper-intelligent doom
creature let's say that he's just a
normal panda okay it's still weird to
have a panda in your underground
fighting warehouse and you should
probably be slightly more concerned
about an unrestrained mega bear
particularly if you are eating a sausage
because pandas are surprisingly
carnivorous like you think of them as
eating nothing but bamboo but they
actually have the digestive system of a
carnivore and will eat meat on occasion
in fact it's because pandas primarily
eat bamboo that they end up being ever
so lazy because it contains such little
nutritional value hence why our panda
needs a sausage good boy moving to
hikari now sadly we don't learn too much
new about him this week if anything no
actually i have to say this whole
section is a pretty low-key way to end
the chapter actually like to put on the
pompous hat of online criticism for a
second it's not an ending that really
inspires me to like go out and
desperately read the next chapter
immediately which might be quite a
merciful effect because there is a break
next week so sadly no jejutsukai sen oh
i don't know though this page still left
me on a kind of like a kind of meh note
i feel like chapter ending should
usually have a solid full stop to them
for example in chapter 153 it ended on a
collage of excitement showing our five
key players of this little mini arc and
building anticipation for their
interactions that was a very nice full
stop that makes you want to move on to
the next sentence and this has become a
metaphor the sentence being the next
chapter whereas the ending of chapter
154 is more of an ellipses something
that just sort of leads you lingering
and confused like this is yuji's first
interaction with hakari but we don't
learn anything or there's nothing
particularly interesting happening with
either character and we know that the
discussion that they're having right now
is entirely hollow akari is offering
yuji cash monies for fight work but
that's the false pretense for why we're
here and you can't build anticipation on
the false scenario because we know it's
only a mask for yuji's true intentions
and the last panel itself is especially
unexciting it's just yugi standing there
completely neutral faced and final
panels are very important because they
are the last image that your readers
remember it's their primary takeaway
actually because it is that final image
and yuji well he's legitimately just
standing there looking about as
unimpressed as i am his face is saying
is is this really how we're ending the
chapter i don't know but just imagine a
different ending where the last sign of
dialogue is either something like akari
saying i know why you're here first year
yuji itadori or yuji saying something
like i've come to speak with you about
something important third year kinji
hikari and i know that those are both
really stupid examples but there's
something that actively builds
anticipation for the next chapter
instead this ending reads more like a
spam internet ad you know how would you
like to make ten thousand dollars
working only one hour per day that sort
of stuff and yuji's just like how did
this spam ad get into my life and look
it's admittedly incredibly nitpicky of
me to point out let alone linger on it
for as long as i have but it definitely
killed the energy of the chapter for me
everything else was incredibly fun and
exciting but the last page was just a
bit of a letdown and you know what come
to think of it this last page actually
feels like it should be the first page
of the next chapter like let's say 154
ended with megami furiously trying to
figure out hoshi's curse technique that
would be much more dire and dramatic and
then 155 opens up with this page of
fukari making his offer to yuji from
which point the conversation can unravel
from there and actually lead to
something substantive it's actually a
very solid first page it's just
definitely not a great last page once
again yes admittedly nitpicky as crap
but that is what i do if i see something
i like then i hyper focus on it and
praise akhitami like some kind of raving
mad fanboy and if i see something i'm
not a fan of then i will take a gigantic
amount of time to lay out exactly why
that is because i don't believe in
saying that you just don't like
something without being able to back it
up even if it is an incredibly minor
feature in fact especially if it's a
minor feature with all of that said i'm
still very excited for more jujut's kai
kaisen in particular i'm very keen to
know more about hakari and discover his
cursed technique and very eager to
understand the kind of madness he's
capable of that causes him to generate
solid respect from characters such as
yuta and gojo and if you'd like to earn
gojo's respect then do go and check out
this video it's filled with lots of
cursey goodness because there's always
more to learn explore and experience
with this wonderful series so i look
forward to seeing you there